[Musique]
combien étiez-vous qu'il y ait deux
papas peugeot ne faut trop échos notez
bien sur vos doigts
was a pas grand club attention il vous
manque un
[Musique]
un paquet pour les pâtes à peluches
voilà voilà donc certainement les fruits
confits que j'ai commandé
oh
bongo court beaucoup un paquet qui
marche
qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi tu
criais le banquet anneaux
je t'aurais pas tu sais
peu
ces bruits de moteur sinon ce n'est pas
ta peluche
je fais la sieste de moi c'est encore
pâte à tarte avec son aspirateur ou pas
d'aplomb et ces maudits de l'invention
on dirait que cela se rapproche
c'est peut-être une voiture ou un avion
[Musique]
je fais tout danger ne bouge pas parce
que ce n'est pas renier pas courage je
suis là qu'est ce que c'est pas tout
je ne sais vraiment plus quoi faire
je ferai que je vais avoir une crise de
nerfs si le bruit continu
qu'est ce qui se passe ici ce sont les
24 heures du bas
non à khanaqinne
un paquet enragé
alors oui j'ai jamais rien vu de pareil
et pourtant jamais vu
[Musique]
on ne couche pas ce paquet est injuste
pourquoi attention pâte à zulte le nom
est un tribun sus pour moi je sens tout
ce à quoi l'on de battre de vitesse je
le veux commando la semaine d'or noir
debuck de vitesse lors des riffs là mais
je ne sais plus quoi inventer
enfin la portée d'une plus entonne cet
affreux bruit de moteur aux 1 500 autres
fans
je me demande si ça existe un grand
modèle